[Music]
today we cancel and uh not for the first
time not for the last disney as you know
disney has for a while now been
discouraging a steady stream of stale
warmed over reheated recycled content
the company's creative brain trust
convened several years ago and the head
guy over there said you know i've got an
idea you know all those really popular
movies we made in previous decades we're
gonna make those again
oh you mean we're gonna we're gonna make
movies inspired by those classic films
no no we're gonna we're gonna make those
same films again you mean like sequels
no no we're just gonna we're gonna take
those movies
and do them again exactly the same
and that was the end of the discussion
it had to be the end because there
clearly hasn't been anything in the way
of
actual creative thought or deliberation
going into disney's recent output
they have simply taken the films they
made in the past and done them again
shot for shot making changes only where
modern pc sensitivities demand so the
latest in this slate of microwaved
leftovers is the home alone reboot the
new home alone which will be available
for streaming in november
appears to have taken the original which
which still exists by the way you can
still watch it and recreated it almost
exactly
except without any of the charm of the
original
never mind the total suspension of
disbelief required to watch a home alone
remake set in the year 2021 i mean the
original only worked because it happened
to have been made a few years before
cell phones became household items but
these days with cell phones the story
should be over in about 15 minutes
when the mom realizes oh he left our
side and just calls him
then again it was never clear why she
couldn't have just called him even in
the original film i don't remember how
they got around that any case
there's a trailer for this abomination
let's watch part of it
it was the night before christmas
vacation
and the fun was in full swing you've
split our family onto two separate
flights mom that's please the family
left for their big vacation is that
everyone the cars are leaving now but
forgot one little thing mum
dad uncle blake
they don't even know i'm here
they don't even know i'm here
my mum and dad have gone to tokyo i'm
totally on my own
you do realize that my ten-year-old son
is at home by himself you just assumed
max was on the other flight we didn't
take a census
we got reports of suspicious people
around 36 lincoln ave i can't go to jail
honey i wouldn't last 30 seconds in gen
pop it's where fresh fish get got nobody
here is getting
got
and we're criminals i don't think so
so sorry i was wrong it's not exactly
the same as the original in this one uh
the kid has a british accent so
that's the big it's it's home alone but
with the that that's what they that's
what they said when they when they were
in their their brainstorming session
they said
i know what if what if home alone
but with a british accent
brilliant also joe pesci's character has
been replaced by the most boring actress
in hollywood that's another change and
all the men in this new version appear
to be submissive dunces as well like i
said you have to adjust for modern pc
sensibilities though somehow the kid
remains both male and white which is
easily the most surprising thing disney
has done in 25 years
maybe they figured they already checked
the intersectional box by choosing an
overweight child for the role i'm not
sure now i want to make just three
points here about this
first
um the death of creativity in hollywood
actually does matter i mean it is a big
deal
you could tell quite a lot about a
society from its creative and artistic
output
a thriving society is an artistic
society
when we as a people
have something to say when we are
striving towards something when we have
a sense of awe and wonder
all of that tends to be reflected in the
art that we produce as a culture
so what does it say about us that our
most popular films and shows are almost
all rehashes of what came before
or else they're franchises where the
exact same story is told over and over
again
where only the title and the timeline
changes
it says that we're decadent and bored
and empty just like the movies we watch
of course there are still good
worthwhile innovative stories being told
we're telling some of them ourselves
here at the daily wire as mentioned
but um we don't have the audience that
disney has
if you want to produce interesting art
these days you're going to have to start
out on the fringes and kind of fight
your way in and it will be an uphill
battle all the way
which brings us to the second point
it's often said that the major studios
have run out of ideas ah they've run out
of ideas no they haven't there's no
scarcity of ideas
as long as the world is populated by
conscious self-aware beings there will
always be ideas
and even a few good ones
the problem is not a lack of ideas
within disney or with any in any of
these other studios
but an outright hostility to ideas
they haven't looked for ideas and come
up empty they've rather exiled all of
the bold and unique ideas and the people
who come up with them
because ideas are risky ideas always
have a chance of offending people
ideas don't always translate into the
chosen artistic medium perfectly
a multi-billion dollar corporation like
disney has no use for such volatile and
hazardous things as ideas
they'd rather put out content with no
ideas and why not because they can
shovel stale garbage into the audience's
mouth and get them to eat it anyway if
you could do that why bother cooking a
gourmet meal
which takes us to the third point
but i think we carry much of the blame
here
you know we complain that hollywood
never puts out anything worthwhile and
all they do is repeat themselves
and yet we continue to give them our
money and ingest whatever nonsense they
feed us
and i do blame millennials for much of
this
i think as millennials we get
too much blame in general for the state
of society a society that was already
broken before we got here thanks boomers
but for this i give us much of the blame
because we have an insatiable appetite
for what we call nostalgia
and so the studios can churn out
slightly revamped versions of the things
we watched when we were kids and we will
obediently just gobble it all down
but we never stopped to think about the
fact
first of all that so much of our
childhood nostalgia is tied up to
tied to media and products and brands we
liked
rather than actual real-life human
experiences
and we never worried about the fact that
our appetites and tastes apparently
haven't matured or changed a single bit
since the age of 12.
and so it becomes a vicious
self-fuelling cycle we remain in
perpetual adolescence which means
hollywood can keep redoing and rehashing
the same films and shows we enjoyed in
our adolescence and the more we absorb
that content
the more we remain in that childish
state so
there are many people to blame here
including ourselves
which is why disney is cancelled all
these hollywood studios are canceled for
producing this trek but so are we
for continuing to watch it hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated